but when I go through a drive-thru I
always say you know I'll have a number
two thanks so much and they say pull up
ma'am and then I'm
like hi hi wait they think you're a girl
literally every time pull up is that all
ma'am yep that's it thanks so
much and then it's me at the window two
seconds later anyway so you ever like
fake a deep voice do I fake that sounds
creepier than my real voice ready can I
have a number
two okay that sounds like a character
like on a puppet show it sounds like the
movie Scream you you ever watched what
is it scary movies I was like as someone
in Scream that does not sound like the
scream voice it's my version of his
voice all right it sounds more like a
muppet that adds up